un informe poco alentador para europa o
fue publicado en plena conmemoración del
día internacional de la madre tierra
incendios inundaciones e intensas olas
de calor acompañaron el 2021 riego
continente donde hubo más calor menos
vientos y subió el nivel del mar
si miramos este fue uno de los veranos
más calientes en el registro un grado
por encima del promedio entre 1991 y
2020 seguidos sólo por el 2018 y el 2015
y si dejamos de mirar la tierra y vamos
la superficie marina en una escala anual
hubo partes del mediterráneo y partes
del báltico que tocaron temperaturas
récord al menos comparado con los datos
satelitales de los últimos 30 años
mientras tanto en varios países del
mundo el movimiento extinción rebelión
como parte de la ola de reclamos que
marcan el día de la tierra exigieron a
las autoridades del planeta tomar
acciones urgentes para abordar el cambio
climático en inglaterra hicieron una
concentración en los exteriores de la
sede de vanguard que administra activos
en londres donde vomitaron petróleo en
sus hangares el segundo gestor de
activos en el mundo de 8 billones de
dólares y es el mayor inversor de
carbono en el mundo con más de 82 mil
millones de dólares
no tiene políticas sobre los derechos
la guerra nuclear ya también marcó el
rechazo de los activistas en bruselas se
congregaron para denunciar que cesen de
inmediato las importaciones de petróleo
y gas ruso
toda la financiación que tiene rusia
viene del petróleo el gas y el
combustible entonces cortar estos
recursos significa dejar de financiar el
genocidio
las congregaciones se dan en un ambiente
de alarma con organismos y activistas de
todo el mundo
advirtiendo que queda poco tiempo para
controlar los impactos de la crisis
climática